[Music]
guys Super Smash Brothers ultimate has
only been out for a little while now and
we here at the score eSports are hyped
for this latest iteration of the
legendary franchise now we thought it'd
be the perfect time to count down the
coolest plays from smash ultimate
tournaments so far and that includes
locals that's like an air dive destroyer
like knowing your dog wit me because I'm
coming yeah I'm still getting it off the
street now bear in mind guys for this
video we are only considering post
release plays because after all the game
has changed quite a bit since the demos
now with that out of the way let's get
on with it with the top 10 jaw-dropping
plays from smash ultimate so far Captain
Falcon is just as flashy as he's ever
been in smash ultimate which is why he
kicks off our list at number 10
seriously just watch his big d it's a
big knee against Magister at don't Park
on the grass
2018 he's been doing this for years and
the crowd is popping off big t do it
coming in at number 9 is nikhat Picchu
who shows flows Roy that he's the wrong
Pokemon to pick a fight with now Picchu
may have been a lo to your pick and
melee but smash ultimate has seen the
little Pokemon ascend to top to your
status with access to some of the game's
craziest combos if he gets one grab you
can do a whole lot at least 30% may be
able to bring back here it goes 100 any
Rardin oh oh you try to mix up the DI oh
my god oh oh let him stand what the hey
t % Oh
I told that was it I had a savior baby
don't count out how to say you don't
count him out beautiful reset of a combo
got that regrab on the top plan we got
that dere oh my god at number 8 is hydra
who shows us that smashes newly buff the
robot is not to be messed with as he
takes Donkey Kong from one end of the
stage all the way to the opposite blast
zone
[Music]
zero strength has always been his
edgeguarding which is why he lands at
number 7 on our list in this plays ero
wastes no time enforcing his opponent
off the stage in just mere seconds with
perfect execution the inkling has no
chance against cloud as he takes him
from zero to death oh I wanted to spy
continue is rain here oh that high
recovery gonna be helping him out there
but gonna be getting back here just the
same 0% your exact at number 6 we have
nairo who pulls off a classic zero suit
samus ladder combo against Sam Sora's
Peach having earned a name for himself
in smash 4 with his flashy CSS play it's
safe to say that nairo will seamlessly
carry on that legacy into smash ultimate
yeah I think naira misjudging his
recovery of course it's a bit tougher to
recover an ultimate compared to smash 4
less forgiving overall but now it should
be a cow unfortunate touka-sama Sora's
trying to keep nairo at bay with a
florida but had a turn up still in their
hand which bounced off the stage ends up
in a really awful disadvantaged
situation therefore samsara and iro the
ultimate punish our number 5 place he's
a lie pull off a sick combo with
pixel-perfect projectile placement
against trayvon taze palutena at super
splat bros the snake player pulls off
some 200 IQ 4d chess maneuvers that
spell the end for his opponent the
anticipated that i'll catch some running
in how many times we've seen that d1 and
how i knows you're coming at him that
grab ready waiting it down from downtown
to only lead for a line what amazing and
creative plays by a lie dude just
literally littering the skies with
projectiles and I searched I dare you to
try and give him a fun that's right the
c-4 on your car was a more
coming in at number four is a goofy but
effective combo from smash fours Wario
Master gluttony Ultimates version of the
beloved Mario villian seems a lot
stronger than his predecessor and this
extraordinary edge guard shows us
exactly why white asleep that we that he
has he played this very very
aggressively he is of course him and
from a general the tongue for good
measure
gluto he's got all the momentum he's got
all the cards in hand and he is plated
absolutely fantastically so far and that
momentum I think is exactly why he's
choosing that press the advantage rather
than hold it if he's in Mario's head
there's not too much to lose and plus
our number three place he's one of the
franchise's most popular characters
execute an insane combo while smash
ultimate is still in its competitive
infancy
many early tier lists have Princess
Peach near the top and the sequence
shows us exactly why watch sm Sora takes
the buzz on his zero to stage our
runner-up places yet another
electrifying Pichu combo this time
courtesy avoid known for being one of
the flashiest smash 4 players avoid
shows us just how powerful combos can be
as he takes zen use mario from zero to
death with peaches lightning loops at so
cal chronicles even with no rage view is
very much so on kill percent and that
that is the main weakness of his
character but lightning loop we got the
lightning loops on deck 6
or the lab just like that dude just like
that there even in the pound air is
gonna connect then you this is a no-fly
zone where are you at boy where are you
guys cooking vegetarian are just so much
out of what yet this plate may not be a
combo but is simply unbelievable
which is why it takes the crown on our
list after years of research salem
managed to upgrade links bow and arrow
into a sniper rifle which led to this
super clean finish in a game against
wizzrobe and this night another you
can't do this link is looking scary
did you see them till now well guys
that's our list don't forget to up smash
that like button and if you do like what
we do here to score eSports and you'll
want to see more well check out our
Instagram page we post videos memes and
graphics you just won't find here on
YouTube and I promise it's not just a
bunch of selfies of me see you next time
thanks for watching if you want more
great content just like this be sure to
hit the subscribe button